Wow Bill's early good hi buddy
perfect perfect dude I'm such an idiot I
thought it was gonna be winter back here
I got this giant friggin coat this are
just smart there's a smart bet yeah it's
supposed to be winter looking like I'm
in here Purfleet weed yeah bill has a
really a really a Randall McMurphy has a
very very Cuckoo's Nest oh yeah he coat
I thought this was my cooler ball black
cat that had the adidas logo on it this
is just one of those ones you bite the
little [ __ ] newspaper stance yeah I
heart New York but you can't win though
if you bring your light jacket it's
gonna be called hey don't like the
weather just stick around for a minute
there's like 48 different states that
say that who else is gonna be on the
showers Louise just talked with the
streets benefit tonight I know you're on
it I'm on it and bees at Brendan Byrne
who else Pete Cory Ellie oh good Bob
Kelly Dave Attell cipher sounds it's got
a DJ oh wow
of course I'm going blank Voss is gonna
host as always yeah he's gonna lisp his
way through the whole program he really
is the worst he insists on hosting every
event he thinks he's like this master of
ceremonies it's like you're not I
actually asked him every year because
you know it's just some people in this
business you respect and there's other
people he just feel bad for wanted to
host the Oscars and this is the closest
he's ever gonna get so I figure no I
love you know everything I've ever done
oh no is always rich was hosting all the
way back to those [ __ ] a virus virus
yeah towards he was always hosting it
and it's a [ __ ] hard job and he's
great at it
he's a halfway decent golfer just in
case he's listening I want to keep
complimenting him than [ __ ] yeah
they [ __ ] ah yeah yeah so he's hosting
it's gonna be great I was that's my
favorite part is when he just shits on
everybody
he really who always get him you find a
unique way to trash him every year it's
one of my favorite things it's one of
the things that's just been building up
all year and I finally have a chance to
say it's Joe DeRosa is also on Sam Jay I
don't know Sam Jay Sam Jay who sent one
of the newer kids okay like we tried
what we try to do was get a mix of you
know people that started before him his
friends and then people that were
influenced sure by by his comment like
when we would get
Michael che or Hannibal Buress I people
like that so obviously Bo Burnham this
year would be like one of those deals
like get you know to me though those
guys are all kids they see on the show I
believe he is not listed here Jessica
Kirsten's on a Jessica Kirsten yep
Jess he was really funny it's a good
opener not on it no he asked him as you
can tell I don't produce the thing all
right
the great Maureen Taryn she puts the
thing together and then she sends me the
list of who's on it like 58 times so
when I come on the radio I don't sound
like an idiot but I always end up
forgetting that's I always forget to I
know you're on it I know I'm usually on
a tell like this before guys I figured
Maureen knows who's on it she told
people who's on it so they're all gonna
show up so all I have to do is know
where it is and when it starts it's at
the city center 7th New York City Center
at 7 o'clock okay doors open at 6 Jim OH
tickets I don't even know if there's a
check oh maybe it's sold out now sold
out oh this all that Joanne I mean Joe
Jesus Christ and half of see children
roses on the [ __ ] doors is on it I
was gonna say you know when you put your
[ __ ] name down
that's fire bar right there all right
well it's a roast I haven't seen two
roast on a while man I'm glad he's
coming back around it's no I haven't
seen him I think it shows a little
superstar out there were in LA
oh he's doing always doing now what the
[ __ ] the name of the show I'm sorry
boss off better call Silicon Valley so
my wife's at bed by the way I'm on La
time I couldn't get to bed till like
3:00 in the morning so I'm on like five
hours asleep air did you fall you didn't
fly it yesterday yeah I did get a minute
like two I'd land around 2:00 2:30 in
the morning
no on the afternoon I had like a 6:00
a.m. flight okay I almost missed the
flight I got there on time my flight was
24
it was leaving at 6:00 a.m. and then the
Gaeta told me to go to was also a
JetBlue flight to New York but that one
was 124 and instead of left at 7:00 a.m.
and I was like 24 124 it's gotta be
maybe they just pushed it back an hour
so I just put my headphones on and I'm
sitting there staring at my gate and
over my shoulder over my shoulder my
flight is boarding and fortunately a big
mass of people got up and moved and had
an pissed off look on their face I was
like I'll [ __ ] did we get canceled and
right as I took it off was like last
call
oh you're just yeah running down the
[ __ ] like a bad Hollywood movie about
going to the airport ran down the jet
way but it was good man how is the
husband a father it's [ __ ] great
loving it love it love it I was actually
supposed to be here for like four days
and I I cut it short shorter just
because I had a gig in Santa Barbara and
then had a 7:00 a.m. flight and that's
just like your kids only gonna be a year
old once and they develop so friggin
fast like my kid couldn't walk two weeks
ago now she's walking so it's just like
you miss major things you don't wanna be
a Harry Chapin song
no but it's like it's awesome and I know
you do give up a lot but you don't even
remember what it is and your whole new
life just becomes you know about them
and I don't know I'm surprised how well
I've handled it being a self-centered
jackass I actually enjoy being kind of
background it's fun like I was telling
somebody last night like like this past
Christmas I went back I went back east
for Christmas to meet all the relatives
that hadn't met my daughter and
everything it was my favorite Christmas
since I like believed in Santa Claus
really well I just went back in there
was no pressure I got married I had a
kid I did it so is this okay bill great
here she is and I could go be the
antisocial jerk off that I am and just
go stand in the corner drinking some
eggnog and it was it was it was really
uh you know you relate to adults
differently people that you knew forever
and I always hate it when somebody who
didn't have a kid goes you don't get it
man you don't get it too you have when I
was like [ __ ] you I get it it's like a
rehabbing a dog but it's more intense I
hate I grudgingly admit that they were
right however what I learned from that
is I'll never do that to someone who
doesn't have a kid like going like you
know trying to act like I'm [ __ ]
Einstein like right get your head around
and I didn't wear a condom and I'm
smarter than you or whatever but it is
it is it's an awesome experience yeah I
see a lot everyone I know who's got one
is loving it I mean Bobby does you I
guess get all the guys is a great dad
he's a good dad he really is a really
good father friend incredible father but
it's guys who wanted kids it's like I
don't know anybody who accidentally just
knocked no why
everybody's Merry everybody kind of
wants to perspective you want somebody
who accidentally knocked their wife up
so you can see is it still is it good is
it like this universal thing right for
you or you like I can't I didn't want to
do this to begin with and what happened
here yeah cuz everyone I know is like
thrilled that they did it I don't know
why knock up somebody or she co get
trapped by a woman you know what I mean
and which I went for that hashtag on
[ __ ] Twitter wait for it to come
around if we're gonna fix the female
male relationship you kind of got to
work on both sides yeah handle that
don't you even those guys I find they're
like man I [ __ ] hate Luke and [ __ ]
girlfriend but er the kids awesome the
kid is all yeah they kind of like
transcends the relationship although I'm
so glad I will not in that relation
collation type of relationship because I
can't imagine loving this kid with all
your heart that half looks like somebody
that you absolutely [ __ ] hate that's
got to be so weird a constant reminder
and they just little mannerisms like the
way the kid eats little hands eating
toast I'm not in that situation there's
been times though where I've been having
sex and it's hard to pull out and I
wound up pulling out like I'm like I'm
gonna [ __ ] come aside you like and I
want to pull you out and some of them
are crazy I'm like I could have knocked
that girl up eight years ago and I'd
still be tied to Italy my favorite part
of that story is when your lower jaw
shut out out and you're like I'm gonna
come and I'm so happy I didn't do that
with someone who I hated those a certain
crazy like the Birdman at Alcatraz you
should have been like whittling some
crazy toy yeah you know believe me I
wish I did it a lot younger
however selfishly I wish I did it before
my daughter and my wife it was better
that I did it now cuz I'm right I was
ready to do it
as ready as you can be but like I was a
[ __ ] lunatic as you knew my 20s and
30s when I met you if when we didn't get
off on the right foot for a good [ __ ]
18 years we're not 18 years no but we
were always awkward because I was like
completely like [ __ ] walled off I had
so many relationships like that for like
when I'm came down here 27 28 till I was
about 40 and
it's so many of those coat you don't
ever have that conversation just talking
about like you know do we have that we
might I love that it meant something to
me you don't even remember it I might be
also a little damaged too so it's like a
lot of the weird stuff I might not even
notice because I'm also used to be
uncomfortable around people I'm so used
to discomfort that it's never any one
particular person it's always oh yeah no
I was yeah
[ __ ] yeah super super super [ __ ]
antisocial but so then but if you're
antisocial yeah you know and you get
around a bunch of comedians then it
starts feeding into like people get like
that was this guy think he's better than
me as this guy right is this guy not
like me you know you know you build the
whole [ __ ] story in your head like I
have like [ __ ] Zapruder films of
different people you know all kinds of
conspiracy then you finally [ __ ] do a
weekend with him like oh yeah he's a
good guy he's fine
yeah touch a bass burger that's what
that was nine part miniseries that I
built in my head about how you
specifically didn't like me so it is
crazy though how look because all of us
are [ __ ] up on some level and like you
forget like oh your other people have
their own [ __ ] too like it's not all
about me like other people think you
said s burger Eeyore they have their own
we're a little psychology I'm all um
yeah
I have I got a lot of [ __ ] so yeah I
don't know what he can do so I I had a
kid later on life so at least I can
least I'm oh I'm aware of how [ __ ] up
I in so you know you seem like one of
the more together guys I know like as
far as your career and the way you work
like I'm a good actor Jim no I I know I
am a yeah oh yeah but you just start to
feel more together when you started
getting like successful when you were
like obviously this thing is you know II
mean no no I I just was more uh I had to
live for 4045 years and make the same
mistakes you know really from which once
you move out to that age before you fire
like okay how am i contributing to this
what do I need to do differently and and
and I kind of figured out how my brain
worked and I was able to keep myself out
of being just sort of walking around in
a mile
depression-like I was never in a
chemical one thank God I was like in
this mild thing and I kind of learned
how to get myself out of it like okay
you know go to the gym try a new joke
take a couple days off from comedy just
so I didn't just start the [ __ ] slow
descent and to [ __ ] laying on my
futon which I mean for the Vai there was
a point in my mid fifties my mid
thirties that it was like Groundhog Day
and I had nothing going on no manager no
[ __ ] agent in that [ __ ] uh maybe I
was with the Steinberg's at that point I
can't remember but I was just [ __ ] I
was just every [ __ ] day I was just
like God years are going by what the
[ __ ] am i doing if I'm taking a day or
two off helps you a little bit like just
kind of like get your just feel normal
again
yeah I find when I'm getting overwhelmed
in this business is like I finally
realized that it meant I needed a
vacation and that usually would just be
like two days but like it's funny
because you know when you work for
yourself you can decide when you want to
work and you think it's gonna be Ellis
is gonna be [ __ ] great I'll work
three days a week like the Jetsons used
to always say we're gonna do in the
future and then you actually end up
working way more and your next thing you
know you'll kind of look at your
calendar or whatever and be like dude I
haven't had a [ __ ] like day off just
nothing to do in like months and that's
the type of [ __ ] that then makes me
[ __ ] you know I'm on edge I start
fighting with my wife and I start
feeling those feelings like good folks
bluh bluh bluh as I'm [ __ ] doing a
great gig yeah and I'm like right what
is wrong with me that I'm doing this gig
and I'm thinking that [ __ ] but you know
I have a [ __ ] up brain so I've kind of
learned to just sort of see that it's
like oh this isn't this this just means
take a couple days off stupid yeah so
yeah if you would have told 18-year old
me that I'd complain about the things I
complain about today I literally would
have broken a glass in my face that I'm
complaining about going to gigs or a man
I got to fly to a gig like you [ __ ]
shut up like this is what you dreamed of
and you got it you come but it's weird
like one's life is what it is you just
how much you wanted and it just becomes
comfortable and you complain about like
any other job yeah
yeah that's like I remember flipping out
about your
new elevators in this [ __ ] building
and it's just like I used to know how to
get on an elevator you just push the
[ __ ] button and now that I got to
push what floor I'm gonna be in like
today I finally got in there going like
this really is more efficient yeah that
they figure out like a cluster of people
what floors they're going on - so you
don't think you'd have to catch every
floor in the way up so I do that a lot I
have a lot of [ __ ] my own little wars
with technology and [ __ ] and then I
realized that you know some of it is
making my life easier you show flying
yeah
a lot a lot you love it love it [ __ ]
love it and I actually am less afraid
when I'm doing that than I am now
driving on now when I drive on a highway
I'm [ __ ] terrified because when
you're up there there's nobody near you
and everybody's talking and everybody
know where everybody is basically you
don't unless somebody's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and they're not talking which is
always exciting but I can't tell you the
amount of times after I landed and I got
in my car and then I just immediately
see some [ __ ] accident I saw what
time I I'll and I think I told this
story
I [ __ ] landed I had a great flight
radio calls were good and everything and
I got out and I got in my car and I
didn't even get out of the parking lot
and this [ __ ] jerk-off on the other
side of the street this guy probably
like 50 years old on a scooter can't
pull it out and he went too fast and
didn't lean enough and his centrifugal
force took him but he hit the medium
strip he high-sided
launched him in the [ __ ] scooter onto
my side it was like two lanes on my side
[ __ ] rolled like a log and slid on
his face for the last 30 [ __ ] right
so fortunately it wasn't a bunch of cars
coming so I stopped and I was the first
guy to get to him and he was laying on
his back like hat like not even
conscious just going like oh he got
[ __ ] up yeah I mean he was our I mean
I like road rash and [ __ ] I flew back
from San Francisco with Joe bartnik and
we were in a car on uber on the way home
and this [ __ ] guy in the left lane
nobody near him
just hit the medium strip and started
spinning look like an episode of chips
from way back and then spun across four
lanes everybody slowed down he hit
though it was like that guy was on his
phone no way he just [ __ ] drove it
like he just was driving
just sort of drifted and part nick was
going whoa whoa whoa and right as I
looked up I just saw this guy spinning
like a top across four [ __ ] lanes and
yeah ever since I started flying when I
get on the highway I feel like I'm
flying in formation it's like I'm in the
like the [ __ ] the middle angels yeah
and misfit Blue Angels I didn't say
except nobody's talking to anybody and
nobody knows when anybody's gonna do
people passing you on the right - and
like 90 it like really freaks me out
well you look at the cars are now gonna
be able to communicate with each other
now they're all gonna have these when
they had the self-driving cars every car
will know what the other ones gonna do
is probably tell me how that's gonna
work considering the amount of times my
laptop crash isn't it so now we're all
doing 80 and there's a glitch in the
system
the houston we have a problem moment
okay and you're napping going oh it's
gonna be great I got a gig up in Albany
I'm gonna sleep the whole [ __ ] way
you know well yeah that's a good point
there won't be any more later than
Niagara Falls six hours later cuz you
didn't set your alarm there's no more
fender benders it'll just be like
colossal explosive death accidents and
this is what's hilarious about insurance
companies somehow it'll be your fault of
course because I'm wondering how does
insurance work at that point where if
you know in a perfect world all of those
cars work there should be no accidents
so then like your coverage should be a
joke it should be like 40 dollars a year
somehow it'll still be the same amount
of money and if that car gets into an
accident your rates are gonna go up you
can't sue the car company I bet they're
gonna make you sign something like you
know when they falsely imprison somebody
sure and then they go alright well you
gotta sign this thing that you won't you
can't sue the state that's their new
thing and then we'll let you out even
though we we both know you're completely
[ __ ] innocent I feel like think
there's gonna be some of that some of
that legal it's not disgusting like if
you sign the [ __ ] prenup this [ __ ]
teen idol from the boy band yeah that's
exactly in pieces I can't one of the
Osmonds if you sign a prenup under
duress it can be overridden like if you
sign a prenuptial agreement like a week
before you get married
that's the contestable a contract if
it's under duress is there any angle
those [ __ ] can't find do I need to but
how come that's not
a plea to go to jail when you sign away
your rights fine because you're fighting
an entire state that has the money to
keep tying it up where you as the
individual are dealing with your now you
know [ __ ] ex-wife coming at you and
you're just you're gonna cave she's just
gonna wear you down you know and your
lawyer will finally just be like look
man this I can tell us his breaking you
and I think he'd just given money yes
I'll get you a beer or something you're
like I [ __ ] it you end up signing that
thing but you're looking at it from the
angle of the prenup should be good no
matter when you sign it which I kind of
agree yeah oh yeah that said hold all
this [ __ ] [ __ ] where they keep acting
like women have no power in society is
one of the great is it really shows how
much smarter women are than men I mean
the fact that they're acting like they
don't have any power every [ __ ] guy I
know if he's in a relationship she's
running it she's running it yeah thank I
don't ever see like a woman ever me like
okay I just got to make sure my husband
says this is okay but every [ __ ] guy
I know does that and by the way if a
woman does say that people go home why
like it's a nice meeting you yeah but if
yeah I got a check with my wife yeah you
gonna do that you know it's hilarious I
actually gave up arguing with my wife
for Lent like as a joke as a joke right
and she was all excited and now I don't
think she's enjoying it because the fact
that I'm not getting upset anymore now
she doesn't know what I'm thinking and I
took away a lot of her cat and mouse
game right how did you do that what do
you do now II get mad huh when you get
mad what do you just bottle it up I just
say cuz now that's a joke it's a bit so
and I and and it probably would have
died within three days but the fact that
I know that it's bothering her it's like
being at the table like oh he's got no
comeback pile on pile on right so now
she's a total good sport about it but
like you know it's it's been like an
interesting experiment to do that like I
recommend that to any guy out here to
actually give up arguing with your wife
and start arguing with them and it like
it freaks them out who starts who starts
most of is it you were hers like 50 50
ah I probably start like 70% of them but
the
30% that she starts is just like you
know I always wish we had like an
above-ground pool that I could just
throw her in sometimes she would get
hurt I get a feeling of satisfaction but
just there I don't know I don't [ __ ]
know you know what's funny one time she
actually suggested that we go to couples
therapy it's like I'm not [ __ ] doing
that like that is that is like the
beginning of the end of your
relationship because now you're with
this person and it's like if you're all
better they stop making money right you
know and then also I think
subconsciously they know it was the
woman's idea so they got to do the
doctor little thing like dr. Phil knows
his audiences women so like he's he's
always gone with the guy you need to
stop so that's what I said I said I'm
not going to that I want to cover so I
go okay you know I don't need another
person telling me agreeing with you that
I'm out of my [ __ ] mind we were
satisfied sigh stuff watch hear voices
joke now that my wife went to get a
couples therapy so now I'm spending $150
have to let me call me an [ __ ] yeah
exactly it's exactly what we went to
couples therapy once for one session and
it wasn't he I didn't think it was that
bad cuz the woman was like kind of
siding with me there was the couples
therapist god that's him
genius but once again I'm wrong I built
this whole [ __ ] thing in my head no
but then my wife was like what the [ __ ]
is she talking about she was taking your
side the whole plague it just created
more fights because she was laughing
yeah I was like so we're not going back
cuz I didn't want to go so they were
just fighting more from doing this bag
that was like one of those wired of
wires you had the lead at the beginning
of the game you scored the first bucket
he just took the thing the whole way
let's yeah enjoy that man that's a
rarity it was amazing for the moment and
then it was like we didn't have to do it
are you a good apologizer yeah like if
you can fight if you like I was a dick I
mean what a story I liked all of this
[ __ ] you're asking me you have to ask my
wife I can't be I am a go-to Blanche
Isaac who is that we dude I am easy to
live with
now that you're not William not arguing
cuz she's gonna want you to it well then
will you admit you're wrong well then
you admit this do you admit that you're
wrong just quickly and then just be done
with it or do you just not have the cup
no I just admit when I'm wrong when I
agree with her then I'm wrong so how is
all this there's two things if you never
mr. wrong right then she's gonna just
start resenting you if you start foaming
up the mouth about everything and then
the other side is if you just always go
yeah you're right you're right you're
right you're right they're gonna get
bored they're gonna start banging
somebody else they need that whole Sex
in the City are they need the drama but
if you're not arguing now for Lent
how do you how do you get out of those
conversations if you're not gonna admit
that you're wrong cuz you're not wrong
but you're not gonna have the argument
cuz it's lame no no if I was wrong I
would just say that I'm wrong but like
if she wants to argue I just say well
you know I can't argue with you because
I gave driving or nothing just be like
look we don't have to argue we can
debate this because I saw this woman
like we went to this [ __ ] mall right
one of these la malls like right in
Hollywood so everybody look like
Instagram ready it was like ridiculous
dude the amount of titties that were
basically out I mean not even side titty
like underneath titty - it was [ __ ]
ridiculous and she's telling me not to
look I'm like how do I not look at that
you know so this woman came by and dude
she was like smoking hot high heels
top tight pants just smoking hot and
pushing a [ __ ] baby in a carriage and
I made the mistake going like Jesus
Christ like oh that's not a mom right
and she just goes why why isn't that a
mom and I always joke my podcast this
isn't how my wife talks this is just how
I hear at my head she says why why isn't
why isn't that a mom and I was just like
a [ __ ] I was just like yeah I don't
wanna argue with you or whatever I gave
it up and she goes no we can have like a
debate about it so I didn't you know I
didn't tell her when I was no good I
just think like ain't even like the male
version of that before some [ __ ]
hashtag starts about this like if I see
a guy with like his [ __ ] you know
Clorox bleach teeth fake tan and [ __ ]
really call it Botox face like Bruce
Jenner how his face used to look before
we're camel in yeah that's one of those
things I mean I'm probably an [ __ ]
but I just look at if he has kids I'm
like yeah that guy is too self-involved
to be a good dad you know yeah there's a
certain level of tired you're supposed
to look if you're involved with your
kids and or maybe
just a troll looking jackass and I was
jealous of her and so I have no idea so
anyway so that was something that would
have been a fight right and probably
would have been more ammunition for her
to bring up later and I just just like
died and I know you're right you're
right I should have said that you're
right you're right unsatisfying for the
other person they don't get that pint of
blood sometimes I want right in a blood
and you're not getting it because the
other person just said sorry like [ __ ]
no but my wife has a [ __ ]
unbelievable sense of humor so she's
she's finding the humor in it too
because I'm doing all of that [ __ ] like
sweetie I don't wanna talk to you in
like you know caressed like but the back
of my hand will go down the side of her
face just acting like a complete douche
so it's like you know that's the thing
that the reason other than the fact that
my wife is a saint that she puts up with
me but she has a [ __ ] unbelievable
sense of humor like that story I told
you about almost missing the flight like
I wrote her a whole email about it cuz I
didn't want to wake her up with the
texture and I wrote it and all like gee
willikers speak you know so you can
imagine how astonished I was when I just
thought about all of that and like she
was like and she just loves wordplay and
all that so she was like she was
laughing so hard our daughter was what a
little kid was laughing at my wife
laughing so I got a big thrilled that I
was made both of them laugh when I
wasn't there made me feel less like a
piece of [ __ ] that I was on the road
even though this is what I do for a
living so I got to be out here you know
yeah there's worse jobs on the living at
least you can bring her with you if you
want to you pick a place you want to go
but your gig
go with ya week that's what I figure I
will do that I'm trying to figure out
how that works but I will I'll figure
out how to do that like I think I'll do
more like you know play a smaller place
and do more shows right and then just
sort of make a I don't know like a
family trip out of it if it's a cool
place I'm not gonna drag them to some
godforsaken [ __ ] City but you know if
I go to a cool place yeah go someplace
you want to go it's nice and just do
[ __ ] three or four nights and why am
i telling you you understand English you
got mean I'm crediting every text all my
texts all the sudden Jimmy the world
travels everywhere this year he's gone
too it's not just England you went all
over here I went all over Europe you are
starting at the end of May and I had
great gigs I mean I got you're a changed
man
you got you up a better vibe you seem
more relaxed I am you're not you're not
angst or awful awful you haven't said
that once I've been here for almost
Jesus all I been a half an hour I feel
better than I have in probably 15 years
I feel healthy I'm good you look happy
thank you yeah I feel great which how
much your listeners not enjoying this
part of it you look great Jim you look
happy you know they probably don't like
that a lot but they're just they get
tired of complaining to like no matter
what you do if you do it more than two
days in a row they're like [ __ ] chain
you know they get bored right so you
know I haven't been miserable for so
long and then they offer their
constructive criticism critiques with
gentle language yeah on Twitter to say a
picture of a belt in a closet you live
in this and use this to hang yourself is
my favorite one I got this week was
somebody quoted something that I just
was riffing on the podcast and somebody
wrote me this tweet about how I was
better than that joke I can't believe
that made it into your act go back to
the notebook or something like that I
want to be like it was a [ __ ] random
line from the podcast but that's why I
get a kick out of Donald Trump like the
fact that like I can walk away from a
[ __ ] bad tweet and he can't and he's
actually a finger on a button it's like
dude you're acting like a 7th grade girl
here what are you doing
shake it off his Twitter his eye
communication is not great like his
Twitter is not good and I wish you would
just that's got to be the biggest
understatement president is tweeting do
you understand
to leaders of countries argued about who
had a bigger red phone or a button I
mean that was like us yeah that was like
you know like when feminists go like oh
and they had like their missiles these
dick shaped things and blah blah blah
and I'm always thinking like well there
is physics and aerodynamics and all that
involved like if you have it's shaped
like a [ __ ] I don't think it's gonna
make it to another country let's you
frisbee it then that gap is gonna
[ __ ] be a lot of drag but they were
literally I was like you know I think
those feminists are right on this one
they got
on that one so I mean just the idea that
he's tweeting at all like just that he's
got that he's doing it and how we got
used to it and it just became totally
like acceptable that this guy was gonna
do stuff like that it's just gonna be
the longest this is just gonna be a long
four if not eight years they can't
wonder how what people were they always
doing that and now we're just seeing
every ugly
what do you mean childish aspect of it
well here's where they always kind of
think in that way where they always kind
of say that stuff in behind the scenes
through diplomatic means but that was
the basic thing of it my dad's bigger
yeah that really is all it comes down to
we get to push around people who are
[ __ ] button is bigger he just said I
have a bigger button he said it like you
said seventh grade what's that sound
like CEO energy you know that like that
like bigger dick ego stuff that every
CEO ever has has had that anytime you
meet with an executive or anything they
had that thing where there's that sort
of competitive alpha thing about him
like there's nothing wrong with that as
long as that energy is focused in a good
way yeah which in business it's usually
isn't it's usually ends up for you again
just pour it in the drinking water we
need profits no I usually I'm not good
in those moments I usually bow my head
and I [ __ ] slinking in full beta mode
you do yeah somebody else later on the
day what nothing to do with that been
there yeah humiliating but yes that's
prising that's what this is except it's
done through Twitter and not the most
eloquent tweets in the world yeah I
agree
yeah it's his weak spot twitter is yeah
it's communication yeah not good I I
have a whole thing on how he got in I
think the Republicans just stepped and
[ __ ] with him I think that both sides
want to change and I think Bernie
represented change in Trump represented
change and the Democrats picked Hillary
which I totally get going like this
guy's a lunatic let's go with the tried
and true and that's not what people
wanted and I think accidentally the
Republicans were offering change and and
that's how that dude ended up it's just
it was like a [ __ ] blindfold
half-court shot and I think everybody
[ __ ] misread it and this whole thing
that they're like Oh Trump got the
racist vote and all that I don't believe
in that either cuz they could have voted
against a black president two elections
in a row and Obama won so right the
racist vote every [ __ ] election so I
just I just think that people bought
into his two-by-four rhetoric I love
that I'm gonna drain the swamp like like
all the politicians we're gonna sit
there well I guess it's over everything
that we did the boss says we got it now
they just all they do is they
rope-a-dope when somebody like that
comes in they just lean on the ropes and
they just right going cuz cuz it's it's
finite the amount of time he's gonna be
in there
I remember when Al Gore was trying to
get like an electric car like they just
he goes you know we demand that you make
a car that gets a hundred miles a gallon
[ __ ] blah blah blah by the end they
just [ __ ] that was still working on
it ya type raise a prototype and he gets
to walk around his hands in his pocket
nodding things are getting done things
are getting done six weeks before he
leaves hey what's going on with it I you
know it's not quite done memo would
definitely get it done with this next
guy go [ __ ] yourself that's right there
open up that's a great way to put it
yeah that's that's all they're gonna
whatever he wants to do as far as I'm
not saying he won't get [ __ ] done I'm
just saying as far as like like his hoe
draining the swamp right changing the
holes like I don't think anything ever
brought both parties more together than
him saying I'm gonna drain the swamp and
then it all like okay everybody let's
lock arms and uh let's not not let's not
let him do any like I don't exactly how
you're gonna do that I think he scares
people too because he's the type that
calls people out publicly in a way that
no one on that level ever call it's
embarrassing I'm so surprised at how
little teeth the press had when he was
running like they got so used to the
politicians cowering with it on a tough
question and he would just answer it and
a lot of times admit to faults and then
they had no follow-up because they'd
never been there right like my favorite
that my favorite one was when they said
when it's like you've said this about
women you've said that about is a woman
asking and you're literally watching the
debate going like oh [ __ ] here comes a
moment you said this he said he goes on
I because I said I said all of that
about Rosie O'Donnell gets a huge laugh
gets rid of the tension and then all the
person has like well you said that about
other women too that was all they had
and then he goes hey you're probably
right but you know and then I was and I
remember sitting then when my mind I was
like that's all you got because he's the
man in a relationship that won't argue
maybe that's what the press is trying to
hit him he's like no I'm not gonna have
the argument like yeah whatever and then
he moves on to something else I mean
literally what she was trying to get him
to say is you have issues with women he
got a laugh and then he admitted that
she was right and then what was she
gonna say well you should stop doing
that yeah there's nowhere to go there
was nowhere to go and then I was just
like I was uh I don't know if we'll ever
see another one like him but I
definitely think that debates changed
like he's like he's definitely a game
changer I mean if I was in political
science whatever that major is I would
be studying that game film going what
the [ __ ] he really understands how to
like like even Oprah I coming up
people's she's such a loved person and
now that she's taught she's not gonna
run she's a degenerate what do you call
her insecure Oprah is this great way of
pegging people for some reason it sticks
whatever he says about somebody seems to
stick whether it's true or not if
there's something so childish about
putting those names on people it takes
is childish and then everybody on the
right well like one person said liberal
snowflake now I love everybody says
liberal snowflake as if it's like the
new joke and nobody's ever heard it you
know we're back everybody says cut now
everybody says been saying that for
[ __ ] decade yeah words vetted I hate
that word you got to make sure you vet
somebody like all of a sudden we're like
these twenty year law enforcement have
somebody in the room you know what I
mean judge their body language it's your
responsibility to vet these people yeah
why yeah what do you the [ __ ] is that
Sarah Palin that was when everyone
started talking about you they're like
she wasn't properly vetted
right that was when everyone started
people knew the word but that was when
everyone started using it after Palin
and it was such a bad choice it was she
wasn't vetted properly shut up I don't
think anybody even realized like the
amount of effort that goes into picking
these candidates before like paling
comes up and they're like well shouldn't
there be well normally they vet these
candidates oh that's what they didn't do
you need to vet these people I have to
think too cuz I even saw an interview
again recently and once again she did
not come off even remotely like it like
this person holds public office it's
just I mean I can go with like okay
you're a little nervous in public you
stammer and it was just like she was
just talking in circles Oh Hillary well
I get I but I get but it's also showbiz
and you know I know she's got that hot
thing she's got the glasses and stuff I
was in for a second till she talked and
I was just like all right people like
her them with little people who like her
like her yeah I never quite understood
it but people who like her really liked
her I guess she represents something
they think I think it's yeah I think
it's back to what you were talking about
about the change cuz even then they
thought that was the they thought that
the Republicans wanted the same change
as the Democrats they were like if we
can get a woman in there we'll get those
yeah baby water well they [ __ ] up on
this time they were like wait no they
just wanted a total [ __ ] like people
will vote and then this is kind of old
[ __ ] but then like Hillary had that
awful combination
she had like Mike Dukakis is charisma
comfortable in her own skin is Al Gore
like that smile that crazy [ __ ] smile
it's just like what is going on between
your ears when you do that I can hear
your your speech coach going you got a
smile more crazy yeah the cadence the
way she would speak and I know Trump was
just like I [ __ ] hated the guy but he
was so [ __ ] funny
he's compelling it's [ __ ] it's
unbelievable it's fundable I liked what
he was like when he kept interrupting
they told him to not interrupt and then
he and it just goes and he goes to the
panel as Hillary's trying to answer
oh I get it three against one he totally
painted himself as a victim he ignored
all the [ __ ] rules and it was just
like and they had nothing there was
these are the rules of the debate and
then he would break all of them and
nobody ever broke them so there was no
what was somebody gonna do go in and put
him in a sleeper hold like how are you
gonna stop him and he just like he
everybody thought it was like these cell
like they were in a Cell and it was just
like a piece of tape on the floor he
just like step right right and they were
like oh [ __ ] I didn't know he could do
that I'm gonna do that you remember the
one it was like the Town Hall when like
Hillary was like standing up and like
you know robotically walking around and
talking to people and he just started
following her so right over her shoulder
he was just like looming there so every
shot of Hillary is just Donald right
over her oh my god I gotta watch that
it's so [ __ ] weird didn't she make
him remarkable years a year later about
how she was creeped out by him being
behind her like that she says he creeped
her out yeah I'm getting creeped out
listening to that yeah who's great but
what ends up happening is nobody's
listening word that she's saying and
they're just looking at it like the
whole story is now him look at he
followed her you can see in that photo
right there he followed her and would
just be right over her shoulder
everywhere she went
oh my well she was stealing focus you're
supposed to sit you're supposed to sit
in the chair while the other person
talks I was I read you it's great
comedic Lee it wasn't great that that
that he won I couldn't stand either one
of them and I and there was I thought
I'm the Republican Democrat side there
was a number of people that were just
way more like just grounded in just a
basic intellectual and human level than
like that I mean that was a I think the
joke I was doing my active time it was
like 2:00 a.m. and at a bar he had to
like pick someone to go home with like
that's what that election felt like so I
don't have the [ __ ] we're talking about
this it's long since done so this is
he's in so we got to do it is what it is
I think we'll be okay yeah I think yeah
I hope we'll get through we'll get
through it
yeah all right I know I'm happier
really interesting it's like now the
Democratic politicians are going around
being like well I know everybody says
such good things about these tax cuts
but it's pennies people don't but even
the people that hate Trump are like just
fifty extra dollars in my paycheck like
I kind of like that he's doing this yeah
there's some sort of [ __ ] loophole in
there we're in the end then it for the
young for the people who are poor it
goes away in like a year or two but then
and then it doesn't go away for the rich
be of course not basically became
president so he can put a golf course
anywhere he wants like I don't know but
I think you know I have you started
doing any that stuff like like you could
you make good money have you had any
like wow I never thought I'd be doing
this in my life but like where you're
doing stuff that like people with money
do or if you remained exactly the same
no I'm just getting the [ __ ] kicked out
of me in taxes like just [ __ ] Elvis
taxes because I you know I don't get
that thing buy a house and then stay in
debt because it's a good tax write-off
and it's like alright so I get this you
know level of a tax write-off but I'm
paying even more interest so all I'm
really doing is just babysitting this
property for the bank the end of my life
I can't give it to my kid because
they're gonna totally get crushed in
taxes so I just buy something that I can
totally afford and I pay it off and cuz
the dream is well I'm gonna pay it off
and then I can [ __ ] relax and then
what happens is is every quarter they
come in and just do they just [ __ ]
tip you upside down and shake it out of
you so it's this is weird thing when you
have the freedom to not play the game
but through like fees and penalties
they're gonna guide your money back onto
the crap table and that's kind of what
I'm realizing so ya know I'm a frugal
son of a [ __ ] dude yeah yeah dude I saw
you know I you know you know the guys I
saw guys get deals and go out and buy
like [ __ ] fur coats and get old cars
and [ __ ] I love that car
I loved in Carbone go shut off [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh yes oh I've always had like the
I get the whole that you know you know I
figured like where I'm at how's it gonna
get better than this so I figured this
is the height of me earning and I know
what the low point felt like and
eventually you're gonna go back to that
I just don't see myself 65 70 years old
and college kids are gonna be like what
is this old man have to say about the
robot that I own or whatever like
eventually I'm gonna be doing like
matinee gigs in the afternoon and so
like I want to have a house that's paid
off yeah you know maybe a couple of
[ __ ] rental properties and I just
want to live a little life you know like
and I am you know I've been more than
happy with whatever this business gave
me years ago
so anything after that has been great
all I ever wanted to do was just be a
comedian that could sell tickets and I
was talking to something about that last
night like the level of of just how
awesome that is like basically at this
point you know anywhere my wife wants to
go on vacation in the continental United
States
I'll be like all right let's plan that
I'll book a gig there one night right
I'll actually make money on the vacation
to pay for the plane tickets and all of
that and then I can totally chill out
and like in my idea of working on the
vacation is to do my dream job right so
I go up there and act like a [ __ ]
idiot and have a great time and my wife
is totally cool I always do that every
time when we go on vacation I have one
night like okay I'm gonna go pay for the
vacation go up and act like a [ __ ]
jerk-off for an hour have the best time
and then I get drunk for the rest of the
week yeah paid for yeah so that's when
it goes back to what you were talking
earlier like how can I ever be in a bad
mood it's because I'm a human being and
I'm a selfish [ __ ] and I'm [ __ ] I
have a bunch of flaws and you know
you're [ __ ] you figure you don't step
back you live in your life with your
[ __ ] hand right in your face stick
and I'm like dude I like this week what
I want to upload my podcast to Dropbox
and it wasn't working
and if you want to see something funny
watch me flip out when my kid is
sleeping cuz I can't yell kit and just
listen to do it I literally grabbed my
computer and I was just like [ __ ] my my
and just doing that dude gritted teeth
like you [ __ ] she showed me shaking
the [ __ ] out of this [ __ ] computer
and of course it turned out I was just
on the wrong page and there was nothing
wrong with Dropbox and then my wife's
looking at me and then I totally
uploaded they had no problem then I had
to play it off like I figured something
out oh there it is like I got what was
wrong yeah if I was more evolved human
being I would have said in that moment
honey you know what there was actually
nothing wrong with that this is my fault
and once again nobody never failed well
there's no satisfaction in that there's
no satisfaction in like oh it's just you
know so you want some I think it is for
your wife it gives them hope that I'm
for her I mean for you can actually
enjoy for me there's no satisfaction I
think if I if the computer thing doesn't
work and all of a sudden I realize all
just on the wrong page like there's no
win for me there I'm just like I'm big
of [ __ ] [ __ ] I thought they
should make a laptop right for in those
moments that you can break but you can
then put back together that doesn't work
because I've always wanted to like you
know you always think of such grabbing
something by the hair and snapping the
head off to pushing it backwards that's
what I want to do to the laptop like
just just want to [ __ ] Biman times
I've grabbed my phone and started to
like [ __ ] break it in half but I
always stop I at least have enough
control of my temper to be like this is
immediately going to add like an
absolute [ __ ] show for the next three
days of your life if you do this so I
start to do it then I kind of [ __ ]
set it down
relax relax yes you don't have a room in
the house where you can get loudly upset
no what do you yell at electronic I have
my angry room invented Charlie's Angels
he had a room in his house just for
wrapping gifts you ever see that no was
that guy's name yes it up the famous
daughter she was on Aaron Spelling yes
yeah he had this giant like
these [ __ ] room houses he pull it up
on on the internet if you can it [ __ ] it
has like had like 36 bedrooms and I know
I was one of those just oddly things
that struck me so funny like this guy
had to buy 36 beds like the the ultimate
night net let me look at that [ __ ]
thing so then what's funny is that thing
you know as they say is that that's the
classic white elephant like like that is
like an over a hundred million dollar
house so now when you go to sell that
thing basically one percent of one
percent of the people in the world can
actually afford it and you have to hope
that they're in the market and they like
what you've done with your 36 bed right
have 35 friends Wow yeah to sleep over I
think I saw that I'm like an e true
Hollywood story or something cuz now
that you say the gift-wrap room for some
reason in my head I feel like I knew
that Aaron Spelling had just a room for
wrapping gifts dude I would literally
slowly go insane if I lived in that
place myself running naked down the
halls like sliding it I I was just not
knowing where my wife was just yelling
her name trying to find her where the
[ __ ] is Mike can you imagine losing your
fight like I know this is like hacky
shitty but just like all of that stuff
well yeah that's the thing like I guess
if you don't because when you have a
family like you got to spend time with
your family like that's when we moved
out of our one-bedroom apartment into a
house I was like we're still gonna be in
the same room all the time because you
don't want to be that antisocial person
you know so I I don't know what you
would do to keep from falling apart cuz
I feel like if I had a thirty six
bedroom house it would be a total waste
of money to just spend it all in one
room like we're my wife and I real I'd
be like no I got a couple to the west
wing of my house I think that house
would actually end my relationship with
my wife yeah we would begin to live
completely separate lives right because
she in a lot of ways you know the
overlap she has some of my behavioral
things and sometimes I think it's it's
because I'm difficult to live with but
then other times I'm thinking like now
you're a little
you know you still you got your
independent streak too so but it's also
what I really like about her so you get
to like her bedroom or that spot of the
house that she's in control if you're
like oh I didn't know you did this to
the wallpaper and she'd be like yeah
there's a month and a half ago and you'd
realize like we're not connected at all
anymore
we're just leave I really think you
could sneak into that house and just
dressed up as like a butler or some [ __ ]
and like he'd be like you know some sort
of chalice but then they finally sold it
in like some super rich Russian guy
bought it for his dog oh and Oleg Archie
yeah this Russian oligarch yeah they're
buying a property all over the [ __ ]
country yes he bought up that big
[ __ ] thing and for his daughter and
this just strikes me as [ __ ]
hilarious like if you go to date or like
how do you top that well my dad bought
me this go to the movies go see black
panther is he alive Aaron Spelling mmhmm
yeah I don't think no he died did you
see Black Panther yes I did how was it
it was good it was it's good I'm not a
big superhero movie guy but it was it
was definitely good I'll see it on when
it comes on it'll be on [ __ ] Netflix
in probably two weeks when is that but
someone's asked you what is season three
f is for family later on this year do
they tell you in advance like how far
how much notice they give you about what
what it's coming out uh it's sort of
vague like we just sort of kind of can
guess like October November something
like that animation takes a long time it
does yes but Netflix is awesome you know
as far as like I don't know they they
give really good notes everybody has
different relationships of people but
I've always like you know you want to be
that comedian like I'm the artist man
don't tell me how to do this and like
though Sam you should over like yeah
that's a good [ __ ] note I didn't see
that that was a really good note haven't
somebody makes sense with a note is
helpful well they were the ones that
said to serialize it to do like making
we know one leads and do another and I
was like now I'm gonna do standalone
episodes with superdude right and then
the second we started writing it I was
like oh this is awesome
so that's the most important note and
the best note out of a lot of good ones
that they've given us they definitely
you know there's a reason why they're
dominating the world right now they're
they're really good at what they do my
last special that came out I remember
they they asked you know we gotta have a
meeting on how to promote this special
right oh my god Jesus Christ what what
the it's a special I'll [ __ ] go on
talk shows and throw some billboards up
dude I went in there and they basically
showed me their algorithms and stuff of
how they did it I like I walked out of
there like I like what this is this is
what it like when you become president
you get debriefed and you walk out of
there with that look on your face like
Jesus Christ I don't know like that so
you mean like where they place things on
the Netflix like I didn't realize like
you know when you sit down if we both
watch Netflix yeah but it's all based on
what you watched and what I watch so my
home screens gonna be different than
yours right
and so they I can't do it I was trying
to get my head was like calculus but it
made sense as they were explaining it
that as I was watching I was like Jesus
Christ this is unbelievable that's why
people don't data is a hundred percent
it or probably already is gonna be the
most valuable commodity to any of these
companies data is what they give all
their bones but but this is the thing
that's all it is but if you can't read
the tea leaves right you're that that's
all I mean yeah information has always
been king but if if you don't know how
to apply it you know right right a lot
of decisions I've made my life access to
a lot of information in my life it's the
application that's your problem yeah
anybody can watch Game film but can you
come up with a [ __ ] game plan to beat
the defense yeah is what separates the
big boys phone there's nothing worse
than you have the information and you
just can't apply it and you're doing it
wrong anyway you still get yelled at by
your parents huh cuz be daddy looks the
same from across the aisle I wish I had
that line
in the day well being addy looks the
same across the island just admit that I
cheated cheated thank you Jim thank you
for not giving me the laughs and just
being like that's very funny I was
trying to help thank you for coming that
feels like when I auditioned for a part
that was very good thank you for coming
in
dude I was bond me on an audition so bad
I [ __ ] up so I try to do the brave
they're going hey we start this over I
missed the end the woman says no no no
we'll just splice it together she
wouldn't let me have such a specific
look as do I like back to even you know
when I had [ __ ] here when I came in
like you know back we had like black and
white headshots yeah
my hair was dark enough that it looked
like I had brown hair so in a lot of
times in the beginning when people
didn't know who I was and that I had red
hair I would come in for the lead and
like they was big hey and we're just
gonna do the first thing and it was like
it was just like things like that's not
our guy they know immediately know
immediately yeah so yet some of that is
like that so I kind of learned to not
take it personally and then I actually I
found it funny that that they were just
like yeah you're redhead that you
weren't up doing I always found it
hilarious but I also had like a stand-up
career and always viewed acting as this
thing that I love to do but it was just
like it was just so out of my control
that I couldn't put a lot of like like I
know it's I don't know how like you get
those [ __ ] like it once you prove
you're funny as a comedian and you're
not an [ __ ] and you're easy to work
with like I go to the club I sold
tickets you're gonna book me the next
writer like actors they [ __ ] go out
they win awards and then they still
gotta [ __ ] called directors and
become just give me a chance I gotta
like you know like when Jim Carrey got a
man on the moon yeah he was making
twenty million of [ __ ] movie was like
the biggest box-office star and he had
to put himself on tape yeah to get it
so like I have such a respect for like
acting and all that [ __ ] like everybody
thinks that they can do it and the other
thing it's like really Daniel day-lewis
like like pretending to be [ __ ]
Abraham Lincoln
a year learning that he had a
high-pitched voice the craziest part of
that whole thing is figuring out like oh
I know that you guys think this sounds
funny but I did the research that's
actually what his voice sounded like oh
I mean like that guy's acting you know
what I mean like there's different
levels of it like I feel like my acting
is like on the joke book level like you
know I mean like I can tell a joke I
could do what you do Jim you know the
people who think that you know the
people who are funny at the water bubble
and then there's actually like the one I
always bring up is um
what's-his-face Anthony Hopkins were
like when he played a Hannibal Lecter
that would have ended most people's
career they never would have been able
to see him as anything else and then the
very next one he played like John Quincy
Adams and Amistad and he was [ __ ]
John Quincy Adams there wasn't a shred
right of Hannibal Lecter I totally
believed it he'd be like a Mel Blanc
thing but Mel Blanc you you couldn't
hear any Bugs Bunny or you sending me
salmon either one of those voices and
then he talked you didn't hear any of
them yeah and he's able to do that
visually as you look at like the way he
holds his body and all of that [ __ ] I
remember to Rosa one time said he's
teach the he watched his sing on
Travolta and Travolta was just talking
about the different walks going okay
Vinnie Barbarino walk like this get
shorty walk like this Vincent Vega walk
like that and it was just like dude he
comes up with walks it's just like
that's right
and then I started thinking of my small
acting career it's like every character
character I ever played walked exactly
the way I did I feel this guy's a lot
like me were you good on crashing I
played myself but they have you have to
find a woman that's gonna put up with a
guy who's acting like Abe Lincoln for a
year how many [ __ ] people will live
with a guy oh oh what about when he did
my left foot she could have pushed him
around the house he retired I guess he
got tired of it it was just too much I
would think so
he's just that or he wants to sell this
new movie it's just last one maybe I'll
come back into the other one did anybody
see that new movie in Thomas Anderson
movie I don't know it's out yeah this is
out I think he came out but I just don't
think you got any kind of wide release I
don't know it's weird
as people like that out there acting
like I it just doesn't feel like hey
you're a good actor it's like it
compared to what yeah I can sound
believable hey what do you think of the
Monique thing with coming out and
complaining about with it they offered
her five hundred thousand and then Wanda
said they didn't offer her that I don't
know when they offered one of the money
the people complaining about what
they're offering them for specials I'm
thinking there's another reason behind
it yeah that's probably that would be
something that I would do the
professional way which is you go through
your your people your agent yeah but I
also think that like nowadays where
there's no due process and complaining
on social media you just all you seems
it sort of appears if you complain then
you get what you want so maybe that
that's that's why it's the strategy she
chose to do that that's not how I would
have done it no me neither
that's tacky you got it yeah you don't
[ __ ] say how much your money now how
much money this other person is making
and all of that [ __ ] that's something
you say you say to them and then but you
always got to walk away friends
you can't like in business you can't
take any of it [ __ ] personal like
that first offer they're gonna slide
across the table is going to be the
biggest [ __ ] over ever for you and they
agree and that's just negotiating tactic
page one sure I'm going to ask for a
zillion miles an hour you know a zillion
miles I'm sorry in the other direction
so when we meet in the middle I'm gonna
get as much as I want but like you know
when you're a younger person you you
take that like or if you're
inexperienced you take it personally
yeah new speakers for a special you know
that's it you know you got you just you
know you don't you don't take it uh yeah
you don't take it personal yeah they do
they are there they will lowball you at
first there's a first humility sure you
don't respect it you had to be student
should that's that's what you're
supposed to do and then you're gonna ask
for way more than you think you're gonna
give them and then you've some way you
meet in the middle and then you deliver
a you know deliver a good special and
eventually but what happens is then if
you're not an [ __ ]
through that process and they enjoy
working with you and then you give him a
good product they want to keep working
with you and then you actually become
friends with them and then it does it
does get easier but like calling him out
I love Monique I think she's amazing and
you want a [ __ ] Oscar she's
incredible but like that's not the way I
would have done it right ya know my
manager read it was not a big negotiator
it's usually the first offer good the
industry votes or manager of the year
that's not a good thing they should kind
of hate you they should hate your
manager or be afraid of them not mind
yeah they love them they like him I love
them how good the greatest every time he
did like he's such a great guy like you
I never heard good
do you watch I guess you do you want you
watch Chris Rock special or do you never
really watch other people specialists I
haven't watched it yet but I'm excited
to see it's good yeah it gets I thought
I heard second half gets like he starts
getting into his personal stuff and it's
really good
really really good yeah well that guy
has always done the work yeah how many
years since he put one out like six
years five years said ten ten ten years
well he's mastered like that whole like
he just knows how to do that like not
you know just be out of it for a second
and right as everybody's like hey what's
he up up to BAM he puts out a special
yeah Beastie Boys were like that if he
like right it's you know they did when
they had an album coming out they were
just everywhere and you got the album
and it was awesome and they did the tour
and then they would just go away and it
was always right as I was thinking like
hey man this guy's gonna put out another
album BAM and then they were back and
then then that's you don't get sick of
them and you're like excited it's those
people that are just constantly out
there you know you start thinking I'm a
gun I'm getting tired of this person so
it's like Boston Boston put up the one
great album you like they they're never
gonna do anything else and like ten
years later they put out their second
album that was third they put out two
all they put out two at first yeah they
put out two and then they finally
afterburner was that as easy tough when
I can't remember I don't know yeah I
never liked Boston no no I liked that
first album and then one
summer my buddy header and cassette tape
and he drove almost every weekend and
just kept playing that [ __ ] tape and
I just I did this like it's been almost
30 years and I think I could finally
listen to it like they just wore it the
[ __ ] out and you were finished I was
finished with that band yeah it's saying
it has nothing to do with the band of
the quality because I sure amazing
musicianship and it is a great [ __ ]
album but like more than a feeling oh my
god can't do it they were just another
band out of Boston can we [ __ ] listen
to something else
whatever I started driving when I was in
like high school I had like one CD that
at that point I was like a mix CD that
I'd burned and it was like those 14
songs or whatever I can't listen to any
of them anymore it's been 20 years I
can't listen to any of them cuz I just
played the wall that you know I've
listened to Led Zeppelin so much that I
think at this point like 10 times I've
had to take like a two-year break from
listening because I'd listened to in
every single album you know I play drums
and stuff and boost absolutely obsessed
with John Bonham and I just bought all
the sheet music all the drum music - all
of this [ __ ] and just like at some point
I had to walk it's like it's like the
guys in Zeppelin aren't even listening
to this [ __ ] this much I mean they've
moved on to other music and I would
always look at Robert Plant he was
always like trying different stuff
country album with Alison Krauss and all
this type of stuff but I'm just like he
is continued to move forward and I am
stuck in Physical Graffiti like 1975
however I do still love all that music
he wouldn't even want to talk to you
about it if you had the chance you know
what I mean like he doesn't like to talk
about it doesn't like to be yeah he's
done with it
he's just done with with Zeppelin he'd
they were great he was happy and he's
moved on yeah
the plus it's hard for singers they
can't hit the notes anymore so you don't
to be reminded of what you used to be
able to do ya can't probably do now live
because those guys actually would sing
nowadays people like sing along with
tracks and stuff I remember Anthony a
long time ago was busting his Robert
Plant's chops and it's just like I
didn't know it at the time I wish I
could have told him that but it's just
like go back and listen to them early on
he's hitting all of those notes
and Baidu that was back then like you
know they would smoke cigarettes and
drink right before they would go out and
then have to sing and just drying out
their voice on two different levels and
then singing every night doing like
three four hours shows and naturally
your voice starts to gets deeper you
know as you get older yeah Robert well
who's we have enough [ __ ] up Bryan
Johnson
we're saying like we asked if he warmed
up and news ago before shows this
because they're the lads but not like
the [ __ ] hard time did you see the I
never loved this I don't hate it if I
don't love it you see the new bathrooms
dude
but do we need [ __ ] six sinks I know
six [ __ ] sinks yeah and by the way
there's a city I don't know if you can
tell there's an issue with the sink
there that's the [ __ ] that's exactly how
I flip out my wife's like where did that
come from
like it'd be I'll be like in a total
good mood we're out to dinner and then
I'll [ __ ] hey you know I love you I'm
the best decision I ever made and then
I'll just come back like do they need
[ __ ] six sinks in the [ __ ]
bathroom I'm gonna have a [ __ ] laser
thing pointing it at me and then the
[ __ ] come there is asking for my
phone I totally left like just hey you
know this is just great it's good to
finally have a night out with each other
well that's what it is there's fight
they added a stall to [ __ ] him which is
great and they took out a urinal
together me and it sinks neither side
because you know what it is it's a
cookie-cutter thing with like two things
of three sinks we don't need six sinks
in instead of adjusting it and leaving
the extra urinal they just took the [ __ ]
it don't you just it's sink Jimmy why
not [ __ ] message that is true there's
not six things there's now eight [ __ ]
places to [ __ ] you're right that's we go
say hey glass is always half full it
needs to be [ __ ]
and this is gonna be a major issue I
don't know if it's because they try to
pack in as many sinks as they could but
the physics are all off everything is
like self thing there's no nozzles on
anything or push things on anything
anymore when you go to wash your hands
your hand is too close to the soap
dispenser
so as you're rinsing your hands the soap
dispenser just starts firing soap at you
even after you've done the thing
yeah it's brand-new and I don't know who
it was like firing like as you're going
the new sinks suck the new bathroom the
new stalls are good here's five of them
but the new fact that we have two giant
things of three sinks it's upsetting
that spit soap at you for no reason but
yeah there's it's a bust the whole thing
is a [ __ ] million dollar bus it is
it's a total waste of everyone's time it
looks great it looks like something out
of black mirror look we're in the future
when you're in there but then the soap
starts spinning and it's like it's
insane I could get over it when they
remove the urinal how do you [ __ ]
remove a urinal that's the dumbest
choice you can make yeah to put in an
extra well there was the thing with the
ladies over there to wash your hands
yeah you could do that but there's never
been sick people in there washing their
hands simultaneously it's never had the
dirt bags that work you don't wash their
hands thank you I know there's people I
used to work at YouTube video where you
run along all the sinks like a loner I'm
not filming in the bathroom necessary it
was a waste of money and [ __ ] boo one
less sink spaced out a little
differently you could add a urinal and
separate the soap thing a little bit
yeah it's terrible it's it's absolutely
terrible they did they just did two
[ __ ] cookie cutters by far for
pushing down and just getting this hope
exactly when you need it yeah you guys
want to watch me put my Invisalign back
in well that's taken after I ate a
banana how you talk with that I had been
all morning whoa I need a bite down on
my crew you [ __ ] cheated I did not
does it hurt I'm joking
doesn't hurt yeah it hurts the new tray
you get one every week this is a paid
advertisement there you get one new one
like every every week so fortunately all
I had to do was like 16 weeks and I've
been wearing them so much that that's
now knocked down to like 13
and it's one of the few like reverse
aging things I was telling Sam that you
can do what does it do well the thing is
with my teeth and a lot of people see if
they literally start coming off rolling
off the jawbone a little bit like I
married grandma and she would laugh like
her [ __ ] teeth roll angled in and
what happens is is the tooth the part
that's supposed to be below the gum line
that has no enamel becomes exposed and
you can have periodontal issues you can
have tooth decay
you don't chew your food you know you
get bacteria heart disease [ __ ] you
know oh wow
intestinal problems death comes from the
mouth Jimmy so everybody's out there
going for the hair plugs I'm telling you
it's all about the teeth okay I'm good
look at me just joking my podcast I'm
starting look like a bald farrah fawcett
a smile oh now I can see it now that
you've said that I never would know
Stevie didn't tell me oh but he doesn't
have heart disease that's the point yeah
there you go didn't have heart to
actually kind of Harry you never noticed
that I had a nice smile wasn't I've only
noticed you at a nice smile I'm saying
it has a change you never caught me
gazing so wait does it hurt when you put
a make in my mouth guard at night hurts
my teeth sometimes I [ __ ] I it really
hurts
um now why do you up in mouthguard do
you grind your teeth at night no apnea
I'm sure I do
but I mean I've apnea it holds my job
you gotta sleep like sitting up with a
chair yeah a [ __ ] elephant and one
time I want to be a normal boy yeah you
[ __ ] like monogrammed like bathrobe
you know a fireplace he pushing my jaw
out when I can when I can sit no I
somebody made me mouth guard one time uh
some old dentist I had and then Amin the
morning was like my jaw was dislocated I
couldn't get my bite back I'd be like
trying to eat soggy cereal and my teeth
wouldn't come together which was [ __ ]
with my mood so I would literally have
to like push my jaw in and then close
and then it would pop it's like popping
your shoulder but your jaws I finally
just said [ __ ] this thing so hopefully
this this fixes and I'll Jam I'm a mess
what do you want for me well your have
you ever needed braces no I never did
but my teeth as you grow older I don't
know the guy was like your jaw continues
to grow
it gets crowded and whatever III you
know he sold me the package and I
thought it cost me a lot of money I
remember when he left he goes he goes
congratulations I shouldn't be saying
that to you don't use BMW so you had
them fitted each one is fitted for your
teeth or these have genius
and I was actually thinking like did I
just get bamboozled into this thing but
now I love them I love them and like
yeah it's exciting to see like your
teeth actually like to be aging and to
see something actually going in a
positive direction is actually it's been
good for my moods you know why are you
self-conscious about it I mean you don't
seem like you would be you look exactly
the same as I always knew something you
all that was down arrows down hit yeah
be like if my hair suddenly [ __ ] grew
back like that level of excitement oh my
god this is incredible
well you know I mean your face you don't
look you look young in your face oh
thank you Jeff yeah I like this okay you
feel like you got to build me up a but
sure you look handsome no thank you or
maybe I'm just kidding be so charming
about it maybe I'm just older and so I
see everyone as I see my site my friends
all look the same makes it but somebody
young like when you say you're not Jim
there was a while there like I was
worried about you who are you yeah you
were a little few like you were just all
mush oh yeah yeah and now you feel like
shredded but through there was a while
there you look like a water balloon yeah
that was bad probably from 2002 to 2010
maybe they went through a real
self-loathing and you would lose it and
then you would have it back yeah like
you you're a oh god yeah look at that
but the snacks were great though huh
they were [ __ ] delicious I'll bet
they were they they weren't they weren't
going now how did you find this what did
you look up fat Jim yeah just Jim Norton
fat is it yeah there's to be with the
Google search Jim Norton fat is a very
very popular search
wasn't one of those things where like
you just thought you were fat but nobody
noticed it's actually a Google a bull
search yeah yeah good fat no but then
you you've been able to keep it off
though yeah I guess this is the age
we've got until we spend a lot of time
just talking about like growing old
yeah but when your friend start dropping
dead you like [ __ ] all right I don't
want to be I know I actually counted the
other day just cuz I didn't want to
forget anybody I know
thirty-five comedians classmates and
club owners that have all passed away
and this is what's so [ __ ] up all of
them are men like when I just out live
later this time a woman just drop dead
picture that like her [ __ ] little
[ __ ] scrunchie yeah flies across the
room and she pancakes under her desk
like that just doesn't happen but
[ __ ] dick you could just watch hours
of footage on YouTube of guys dropping
dead remember that umpire turning around
walking to the backstop just faceplant
just dead yeah it does it does go fast
it does go fast when you I think that's
the way to go you just want to drop dead
one minute you're saying something like
spinning you're gone you never even saw
it coming
calling it a heart attack he's fine him
he's doing better now that was a minor
when he cut got him selling if he called
and they came and got him but do you
know can you imagine dropping dead
though just the randomness of like your
last words you like what was the name of
that actor and welcome back cause
nothing profound
the worst is if you ask and the guy's
about to tell you and many drops dead oh
that was [ __ ] yeah the only the only
visual I can come up with him that
happening to a woman it's not real life
it's that you see about Schmidt when the
wife yeah oh god was the white it's
great movie but the wife drops dead in
it while he's out getting herself he's
out of the house and she's just
vacuuming and then he comes home and he
sees his fat old wife just sitting there
with the vacuum on and she's just face
first on the ground and her shoes a
little askew yeah like that's what it
looks like to find someone dead the
vacuum is going and she's laying there
or dumb shoe is askew and he doesn't
know how to handle anything in the house
old Jack Nicholson in that movie oh my
god that's the worry and you lose your
best friend yes the [ __ ] well that's
that's my god that's right I kind of
like that get that guys go first cuz I
think women can emotionally handle sure
you know you know the deal they'll cry
for ten days and all your shits going
down code will
your overcoats and hats do you panic
about that or do you not do you not
think of it no you can't lose 35 people
and not realize that that's that is a
thing that happens so yeah no I do I do
think about that and there's people that
I worry about there's been times I've
worked with people that are so [ __ ]
out of shape that I actually get excited
that it's now acceptable when you give
somebody CPR that you don't have to do
mouth-to-mouth because you know like ten
years ago
I think this guy's gonna die man I'm
gonna [ __ ]
I'll [ __ ] punch his chest a couple of
times but I'll just anyway and you try
to tell people within they already know
the answer it's that they're not gonna
listen we're gonna say that's gonna
change him nothing ya know how many
people have to drop dead but I get that
cuz you never think it's gonna be you
yeah you don't ever think it's gonna be
you and then until one day like oh [ __ ]
it's me I the best death story I heard
was was Lou Reed was he was like in his
hospital bed and the one of his friends
said he just like enjoyed the experience
say he had this amazing look of
wonderment on his face like oh this is
what it's like to die it just seems like
I don't know like the dopamine or some
[ __ ] that's supposed to come out dude
what the [ __ ] are we talking about death
for that's okay we're doing a benefit
for our dead friend that's right
celebration of death and life eration
within you want to watch Fergie sitting
in the nationally I would like you to
yes watch that you think some of her
voice is good all right guys listen I
gotta go I got it I don't want to watch
this I don't wanna watch and I feel bad
for well we don't have to shoot him -
maybe maybe it might actually be okay
might be good oh it was better than I
thought it was gonna be it might be good
I don't want to watch this come on guys
come on how about until you until you
don't like it have a heart Wow can I put
my coat on we'll turn it off when you
don't like it I mean guys are you doing
a bit no no I was here
fangled banner all I think is there look
for the grace of God go i announcer it
kind of a list bidding me a little bit
[Music]
nice feed it up this seems like the
ending of a movie yeah like a movie
about New Orleans would it work
perfectly it probably would have been
nominated for a Grammy I just thought
the choice you GCRs Arthur
[Music]
I actually like this okay all right
we're back we're back
it's great it's like George Gershwin
does the [ __ ] that she'll anthem or
some [ __ ] kinda like that part the
funniest part is then panning over the
players and they gotta keep straight
faces they're like what the [ __ ] dude
from the [ __ ] war is he's like Jimmy
can't stay good for her she did she made
her to rock yeah she did great good for
her is right LeBron losing it it also
kind of sounds like you know happy
birthday yeah mr. president I don't know
if this won't be as iconic as that one
was maybe not for the same reasons but
you wish you would have done it a little
bit more she [ __ ] what she said let's
play some basketball she can sing
theoretically yeah like her voice
sounded fine I just didn't like that no
I have to go you got to look search
Fergie flip let's look for Fergie photos
before takeoff yeah let's take up for a
play is this from the Today Show is this
it yeah okay
now
okay here we go she looks good turn it
up turn up
[Music]
[Laughter]
how can you she stayed on key with you
you know what it sounds like
it's endless like she got possessed
somebody else took control of her body
but her voice was still something else
she's doing one-handed cartwheel says
she didn't [ __ ] impressive that was
their pants she did peer cause high
she's great how old is she like 40 I
don't know probably 40 and earlier she's
[ __ ] sexy man yeah well great time
Maureen says hi to both apologize why is
she apologizing for her performance she
just didn't made choices people do that
so what there you go cuz that's the
smart move cuz everybody uh now she's
apologized and I feel bad she's wrecking
power I feel bad Wow